okay I don't know what my hobbies are I
don't play video games I don't I
him and I are the polar opposite when it
comes to hobbies why cuz I don't sleep
all day you don't you don't play video
games I like physical stuff yeah you
like being physical I like stuff I like
to go do stuff I like taking walks okay
you hate walks okay cuz you're 35 right
yes you know I'm 35 okay
I'm 47 right mm-hmm I am 35 dude yeah 35
what yeah were you taking while you were
doing the exact same thing you're doing
now Chariots of Fire bro
really yeah run champ you are running
champ yeah yeah Chariots of Fire
charity wait when I said chairs the fire
you should have said and no you got that
wrong as a producer but you do like you
let it you let it let me say it and then
you're gonna air it and make me look
like a fool you [ __ ] did it sound
athletic you ride around in a cart
that's what I don't have to do anything
I wonder if you would ever in your
entire lifetime like set a goal like I'm
gonna do the Newton the Boston Marathon
me don't have him I wonder if that's
like a tangible like something that that
can never have it was life I try I went
to the Boston Marathon right don't know
what right okay be careful tread lightly
yeah
Boston Marathon sensitive part of New
York switch to New York yeah okay
I wasn't what that wasn't in a New York
one though you were you don't let me see
my Josh go ahead and say it no I can't
say it now guys now I don't even know
how it goes now that's a problem it's
not good it's not good what I was gonna
say what does it mean no it's just that
you know I mean somebody else bought
their backpacks it's something like that
but you know man they didn't work out
how do I get it that's funny it's mean
but it's bad it's bad man it's bad it's
like when ice tragedy every time I come
back from New York yeah every time I say
to somebody in LA I say was last time
you been to New York I said not too long
ago and I say you remember those two
buildings
they're gone they're like not even there
anymore and I say it dead serious yeah
yeah what he talking about there's like
a big one there now yeah
kind of strange man there really that
city changes every time I go you know I
really building up that what does he say
what responds to you they don't know how
to react yeah I don't know how getting
her from dead seriously I said tell like
barista so I said to a guy's Starbucks
yeah you know what in New York yeah bro
those [ __ ] buildings gone at city's
changing my gentrification if I'm at a
coffee shop or a Starbucks and I heard
like a popular song like Michael Jackson
I always go to the counter who is this
yeah beat it by Michael Jackson I'll
write it down in your phone yeah I'll
just because I like I know no that's so
that was it Michael am i is that I know
you're I convinced them that I don't
know what Spotify you [ __ ] with people
all the time in public always I don't
like the people that I don't like
generally are people that think that
they have authority over me yes a well
they do kind of have authority over you
no they don't
I mean I could literally make you not
take a flight it's fine he'd love that
so that is authority if they say you
can't come through here that's authority
yeah I mean no there aren't no you're
wrong about that because I'm saying is
it's like if they cross the line
something they cross the line how do
they cross the TSA B what do they do do
you know what they do what do they do
Bob what are you like when you give them
your passport your slice ins and then
you're like ticket that guy mm-hmm and
then after that you put your [ __ ] away
right mm-hmm
but sometimes you'll have a TCA got it
guy come up to you and go where you're
going what do you say it's none of your
business
yeah why wouldn't you just tell him
because I already did that I know but I
did that maybe he just making
conversation
no I know what he's doing he went he
he's he probably went to like a TSA like
seminar seminar of some sort right yeah
and they go it's really good to you know
cuz sometimes you know they can get past
that person so it's good to throw that
out there to see you know the people
off-guard hmm but I don't like it the
true Civ you think you're a terrorist
I've never terrorized anybody in my life
well there's no has there been an Asian
terrorists here in the United States I
always get stopped listen you do yeah
cuz of my name yeah yeah yeah so is my
sister
Kayla yeah they go come here for a
second oh yeah come here
[Music]